I don't like red wine you see if I'm a
drink red wine it needs to be like a
specific plan in motion and it needs to
evolve bed.sleep bored of it
that's where think you know then it
stays at teeth please y'all this is Joey
about us
and these are my century okay so this
right here is a bottle of white wine
obviously but it is a special white wine
is specifically Sancerre so since there
is actually Chardonnay it's made in the
Sancerre region of France and it is my
favorite white wine and I need it
everywhere I go so usually I'll put it
on my rider but sometimes I bring one
just in case cuz because they don't get
it right or they couldn't get to the
region of Sancerre for whatever reason I
don't really start drinking I was like
we're like 22 or something like that
like we're like well 21 that's the age
that usually it gets legalized here in
the US so started drinking like around
that time I wasn't really into drinking
I realized that like I was getting
really no so I was like got me something
like a little bit more chill and then I
got introduced to one you know I was
like yeah this isn't my type of
brightness my speed and then one time I
went to so house I was able to kind of
whitewash you have and they said sauce
they're not just like the way it sounded
I was like I feel it that sounds like it
tastes good and they brought it over and
it's been my favorite one ever since
these are both forms of tobacco
this is fronto leaf I take it out so you
can see usually comes from like islands
and it's pretty much just a tobacco leaf
what we do sometimes is as you can see
it got the veins like we'll take it off
of the strip and then we pretty much put
it in the papers did the wing on top of
that and then roll that and in this it's
pretty much this but it's just dried out
like super dried out instead of a soft
leaf form it's like more like
traditional tobacco like you will buy
like American spirit or type so we call
this problem this is sponsor leaf foot
when is in this form is called problem
either or is what I need to smoke or
Rose I don't smoke
this is a Island tea you know I mean
like a lot of people from the Caribbean
this is their preferred way of smoking a
Dutch or backward it's basically this is
a tobacco leaf but this is non process
backwards we have a maggot sorted the
pesticides and all types this is like
straight off the tree show off the plant
life we won't direct-to-consumer mmm-hmm
[Music]
shout out to retro Zulu future I almost
didn't bring this here because I was
like we don't have a deal yet but you
know what maybe this is sparked it
there's a shout out to retro super
future this is my sunglasses case and
it's pretty essential for me because
it's just a easy way to keep all my
sunglasses in one place sunglasses is
such an easy item to loose this
definitely helps me make sure when I do
have those type of nights where we have
a lot of fun there's no crazy pictures
that come out yes real essential
well I ain't gonna lie this ain't like
my whole real line up I just had to
throw some things in there cuz I was
coming through today these are also
super glasses I like this is really cool
oh these are actually the Joey badass
special solar eclipse glasses you know
when I went blind from the Sun I
remember that to protect my eyes after
that happen jokes by the way that never
actually here we are Beast Coast beats
pill this is super essential everywhere
I go I travel a lot
listening to music is essential so I
always make sure I bring a little
portable speaker so we can get jiggy no
matter where we got but this one is
super special to me obviously because
it's a beast Coast beats collab it's
only like 20 of these made you can't get
it nowhere
it's about manga you read this you
should so this right here is obviously
the book this one is a set of our if not
giving it and this is just essential to
me because I always have a book with me
like anytime I'm traveling or only
toured this is the one that I'm
currently reading right now a very good
book by the way shouts of Mark Manson
after school I feel like a lot of us
struggle with you know brain stimulation
passed out like we get a job or whatever
it is that we get into and a lot of us
tend to forget that we need to
constantly like you know be teaching
ourselves and having that urge to learn
that's what I like to read because I
always get to going these journeys for
knowledge for self instead of just
waited for life and people to teach me
things I like to go out and get it
myself so I could teach people things I
don't like candles or reading on my
phone because I'm just gonna start
switching between apps anyway and like I
like the real thing I like tangible
items things that I could feel artifacts
okay the kids are tomorrow and gonna
know nothing about that so I'm just stay
close to mom
[Music]
this is a Louis Vuitton jewelry case it
keeps all my jewelry together and in
style you know it got like these little
compartments put your chains and they
don't get scratched up change my rings
even keep my crystals in here oh yeah
you know we'll we'll save the the
jewelry for the next thing that JQ does
yeah this is exactly what it looks like
is a hat bag hats get damaged in bags
and clothes and a whole bunch of
compiled on top of it so shout out to
hat Club because it's where I got this
shot to Joe French goods I got the nice
new york collab born right now horn New
York's tomorrow oh yeah it's the bottom
our joint you know it's my custom joint
another customs always better
you get the gist though half-assed keep
your house safe and uncrystallized I
wear a lot of hats
in real life so only makes sense
[Music]
so this is my toiletry bag believe your
time keep my like my deodorant my lotion
come on
I seen the Ferger he said he was gonna
show his cologne psycho show my your
mother smelling like me him I like that
you know but I can't to say where I go
make sure I keep all of the toiletries
nicely together in one place because you
know love gotta look right presentable
this is classic it's funny I see no
other rappers say that a Macbook was in
a sense this is essential for me you
know I'm saying when I'm on the road on
whatever I gotta jump it to work mobile
studio mode or whatever mo MacBook baby
take that oh I'm in the office where aw
man or I'm in the movie theater I don't
know what I'm doing you know I'm saying
I might be binge watching her song yeah
MacBook is cool I really struggled with
bringing this hair because this is super
etc to me this is my little black book
this is what peace me able to switch my
hat so efficiently go from act into
rapping to the CEO I just realized that
I was forgetting to do things too much
it was like one thing that I forget to
do it in two weeks ago but I'm like I
couldn't did that two weeks ago I've
been way for our head so this little
black book right here keeps me all
together anything I gotta do ideas
whatever I put it all right here is
still black book
no this is not for wraps I write raps in
my head what's in this book I can't keep
in my head if that makes sense you know
I'm gonna lose it so yeah and if
everybody a child touch my booty you
know gotta say what's gonna happen but
it won't be nice peace artist is Joey
badass logging off my centrist hope you
enjoyed the episode shot the GQ piece